okay this is a really tough video for me
to make
so I'm from Sweden okay you know it not
a secret lot of Swedes have the most
stuff not high taxes shut up good
internet good internet even as a poor
Sweden living man
hundred hundred Internet what's the
standard god damn it
it wasn't something you had to fight for
it was your god-given right sorry sorry
I went too far i'm a christian channel
Christian channel
as you know I don't live in Sweden
anymore for quite some time and I know
what you're thinking Oh UK internet
that's not so bad
that's not like living in a third-world
country right you're wrong I was a fool
if you don't think it's that bad let me
show you let me show you my internet
right now okay okay you want to see this
do you think this is funny
just wait until you see my upload oh my
god
it's depressing it's not even moving god
damn it oh wow shut the hell up you
think I haven't tried
I'm the biggest youtuber I deserve
better in it
yeah damn it I'm better than this now
you may have seen me rant about this in
the past that's because when me and my
step first moved into UK we lived in
this flat for some reason in in UK it
takes two to three weeks to get your
internet installed if you switch
provider the BT has to come in they have
to do I don't know what they do but they
got to do what they got to do and they
take two or three weeks to get there and
if you miss your appointment you gotta
wait another two to three weeks and so
on and so forth so what I had to do back
in 2014 was that we didn't have an
internet so I legit the house had to put
the video on my laptop and then I would
walk out trying to steal neighbor's
Wi-Fi that had better internet because
you you take one road down and someone
would we have fiber here but no not here
who knows why set out to find neighbors
that had unlocked Wi-Fi so I could
upload the goddamn videos I did this in
like 4 a.m. sometimes I would come I
would come back home I forgot my keys
I'd have to climb through a window not
to wake up Marzia so eventually you know
YouTube money came and me and Marcel
were like ok enough okay
enough we're gonna move somewhere where
they have amazing internet that's
impossible because I live in UK but
decent Internet and we did we did move
there we had great internet and
everything was peaceful
everything was nice the world was
finally in harmony then why am i back
here Felix why are you
here with the [ __ ] in it just go back
there and stop complaining like a
son-of-a-bitch
it's a long story okay I'm trying to
tell you the story well I used to have
an office when I was working with Disney
and they were willing to transfer that
least to me but it was a three-year
lease which would have cost me one
hundred and thirteen thousand pounds and
I'm like ah I don't really feel like
paying that when I can just stay here
for free
I just need one shitty room that I can
record from I don't need this giant
office it really doesn't make any sense
oh well if you're so chic oh yeah like
you would pay that amount for Internet
would you you think I should pay that
amount for Internet is that what you
think good for you okay not everyone is
a [ __ ] you should just come to portico
because we have goodish you think I
wouldn't go back to Sweden sorry I need
to calm down okay all right so I had to
pay a hundred and thirteen thousand
pounds I said no you know what I'm gonna
look into it maybe I can get good
internet install in this flat which is
my office and I can't go back to the
other flat because we're renovating that
one right now I forgot to tell you
though all the floors are gone all the
walls are gone I can't even I can't even
go back to my original house we're
staying here temporarily I'm stranded
here
so I basically said three months ago I
was like okay well I'll look into it and
then I found you can get a leased line
which is basically used by a lot of
companies they install a private line so
that you don't have to share internet
with anyone else and you get a
guaranteed speed of a hundred hundred
even a gig a gig a gigabyte a gigabyte
in it oh yeah I'll take it I'll take it
thank you very much I'm tired of living
that whatever like that Internet not
anymore
I can't afford it I'm gonna pay for it
god damn it so I ordered it three months
ago where is it you know who you are
where is my internet where is my
internet where is it where is it where's
my internet I ordered three months ago
you said maximum 47 days so what have I
been doing in the meanwhile then these
three months well I've rented Airbnb I
rented them for a month so I at least
have a temporary solution I bought this
temporary setup
so that I can stream I can upload I can
send files to my editor I can do all
these things smoothly and nicely and no
one have to worry about it but Airbnb
only lets you rent for a month there's
some legality to it you have to put your
name on the council bill or some [ __ ]
like that if you go longer so I had to
switch Airbnb naturally before I rent
the air B&B I'm like okay so what's the
internet in this place I look it up you
know I make sure I asked them okay so
this is a bit weird for me to ask but I
need really good download but also
upload speed okay
and I need you to confirm me these
speeds it's very important this is very
important and I wouldn't get an answer
from this lady she was like it's really
good speech we have really good speeds
in this place come to my little B&B
we have great internet you [ __ ] lying
snake you lying snake it's even worse
than my internet so I'm stuck with this
other place now where my temporary setup
is set up with god-awful internet that I
can't use I can't use it
I can't stream from it it's too bad so
what do I do well it has 4G at least I
get a 4G reception in the Airbnb so I
bought like a box with 4G a 4G modem and
they only let you buy 400 gigabytes per
month otherwise you can't you can't use
more and I'm like can I refill it and
they're like no 100 gigabyte that's what
you get
I'm like I can't just use 100 gigabyte
ok that's gonna run out so fast you
don't understand you don't understand
do you know who I am I never used that
car before but I just went Do You Know
Who I am excuse me
I am cutie I didn't actually say that
but I have 18 I have eighty seven
gigabytes left guys just wanted to tell
you that's why I'm making this video I
even looked into the idea of installing
one of those antennas on the roof it's
15,000 up front which is fine I'll paint
I'll paint but it's for week's
installment and I'm waiting for the
least line so I might as well wait for
the leaves line right and I want to suck
its two contracts oh I'm dying
guys I'm dying that's why I'm making
this video I am dying if things don't
change I am going to die I'm asking for
help
I am sending out my echo signals like a
whale asking for help
gave me internet before I die I'm going
to I'm this is it goodbye
I have ABS 86
I have eighty six gigabytes left before
they get me then it's ten P per megabyte
you
the sense morale of this is that if you
have good internet don't take it for
granted like I did take care of it
appreciate it
make sure it knows it is loved because
one day you may not think it will happen
but it happened to me goddamn it the
Internet it's gonna fade away
[Music]